Actually, by the book this equation for gravity--this equation for the force of gravity--
is only true for point masses.
We would have to concentrate all of our earth in one single spot.
So do we cheat when we don't do so?
The nice thing about gravity is that this equation still holds
for a rotationally symmetric distributed mass.
This is called Newton's Shell Theorem,
and you are going to see in the upcoming quiz why this is called "shell" theorem.
To see why Newton's Shell Theorem holds,
it's best to introduce an analogy to water.
This looks outrageous, but please bear with me.
If we leave our first mass where it is and move the second mass around,
we can determine a force vector at every point in space.
We get a force field.
Imagine that this wasn't the solar system but a pool of water,
and the water has velocities,
and the velocity of the water is described by our force field.
Water flows downward here at a high speed.
It flows to the right at a low speed at this point.
It flows to the left at a somewhat higher speed at this point, and so on.
We interpret the force field a velocity field in our pool of water.
Of course, we're ignoring the units of measurement right now.
Of course when setting force equal to velocity we're ignoring
units of measurement for a moment.
To make that work, there has to be a huge drain in the center.
The first mass acts like a cosmic drain.
Why can we do so? Why does water behave in the same way as this force field does?
To understand that consider two imaginary spheres in our pool,
both centered at the drain.
And the radius of the outer sphere should be twice the radius of the inner sphere,
which means that the surface area of the outer sphere is 4 times the surface area
of the inner sphere.
All lengths are being multiplied by 2.
These are square meters.
They are multiplied by 2 squared.
Now the important quantity to consider is the flow of water through these spheres.
How many cubic meters per second flow through these surfaces?
This number has to be the same for the outer and for the inner sphere.
We are not losing water or gaining water in between,
but as the outer sphere has a surface area of 4 times that of the inner sphere
the velocity has to go up to transport the same amount of water per second
through each of these spheres the velocity at the inner sphere has to quadruple
as compared to this velocity at the outer sphere.
This is precisely what we saw before with gravity.
As we double the distance the force shrinks to 1/4 of the original.
Of course, this doesn't only work for a factor of 2.
This works for all ratios.
Hence, we can indeed identify the force field of gravity with the velocity field of water.
Once this analogy between gravity and water is in place,
it's easy to see that the flow through each of these surfaces
has to be the same.
Let's assume that we have three masses at the center of this sphere.
And this same masses are at the center of that smaller sphere.
And the same three masses are somewhere inside this weird closed surface.
Then the flow through each of these surfaces has to be the same.
If we replace the force field of gravity by the velocity field of water,
we have to seem the same number of cubic meters per second
for each of these surfaces.
Because we're draining water in three spots at the same rate.
Somehow that amount of water has to enter from the outside.
And it has to be this same amount of water,
because we're draining the same amount of water in each of them.